please be unto you welcome to the Dean
show I'm a dear host thank you for
tuning in for another exciting episode
Chinese Arabic English Sheikh Chao is
here in the Dean show he explored all
different ways and walks of life before
finally concluding that this was the way
of life that delivered the purpose of
life based on proof showing that it was
the truth and we're here to experience
things from his perspective because it's
his story so we can all benefit here on
the D show don't go nowhere we'll be
right back with this incredible story
here in the Dean show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the thing this is the thing
[Music]
sheikh chao how are you welcome to the
deen show thank you thank you does that
look hey I'm pleased to be here thank
you for finding the time to be with us
here on the Deen show his safety so you
were born in America I was actually born
in Malaysia Malaysia so your but your
background your Chinese yeah you speak
Chinese yes I can speak basic Chinese
basic Chinese yes how do you say only
one God in Chinese do ease and duty Shen
yeah
listen what is in China how many murders
over a hundred million Muslims it's true
or it's exaggerated how many Muslims are
there in China actually two you're
honest with you when it comes to the
exact number of how many Muslims are in
China
you always find like so many different
numbers like fifty a hundred million
we'd never know the statistics because
the government they're they're very very
secretive about these numbers yeah
what's predominantly the main religion
over there I would say that the
predominant religion is basically a
theism atheism yeah people over there
they really don't know much about
religion and so if there was any other
religion or faith it would probably be
local tradition local beliefs like
Buddhism or Confucianism or whatever now
is this because this is imposed on the
people for instance in the former
Yugoslavia you had the Communists who
are running but the people still they
had the fitrah they had that natural
disposition to believe in the one God
so you did have some people who because
you know they fell under communism and
that they were looking down upon people
who are religion but at the end it
prevailed that belief in the one creator
prevailed is this kind of do you see the
same thing kind of in China obviously
because I've never been there
I really wouldn't be able to say whether
or not it's this or the other but I
think in general over there because ever
since like I think the 80s there has
been this dramatic cultural shift that
just followed the Cultural Revolution
where the communists tried to erase like
religious books and all of these things
so as a result people have been
very much driven by money and becoming
very very prosperous and so as there's a
lot of people I think just don't really
think about religion as much I see
monies on the mind but people talk about
money right sports what's the main sport
in China would it they even got a
basketball league now don't they like
MBA yeah I think they have something
like that yeah so we're talking about
more serious things purpose of light
because we're all headed towards the
grade so we want to be prepared for that
moment when death comes that we're not
sleeping because that's the reality
indeed indeed so it's amazing that
because we're here focused on clearing
the false fallacies of Islam delivering
the pure message of what the purpose of
life is with truth and proof so one of
the misconceptions is that people think
now that Islam is about being Arab
that's an Arab thing but now they see
you they see me I'm an American you're
also an American also with Chinese
background so it's LOM is for everyone
submission to the one guys for everyone
so you also out of your love for this
way of life the way of life of all the
messengers of God including Abraham
Moses Jesus in the last and final
mission from Humpy's before you actually
went to study at the prestigious
University of Medina tell us a little
bit about this well to explain how I
ended up going to the University of
Medina actually I have to give a sort of
a background of how I came to that when
I was younger my father was very very
keen for me to go and memorize Quran and
half way and I'm not embarrassed to
admit this halfway through memorizing
the Quran I felt there was this huge
disconnect between what I was memorizing
and the relationship that I was having
with allah subhanahu wata'ala so for
some time I actually started doubting
whether or not this religion was the
true religion how dare you can you do
that even know so you're doing whatever
there I mean it but anyone that's that's
the natural thing you just you're
questioning so what happens you're
questioning you're doubtful about some
things what happens well I think the
biggest the biggest concern or the
catalyst that made me think like this it
was predominantly the treatment that
iris
sieved when I was in misogyny and
Islamic centers I felt sort of distant
from everyone I felt that the massage
weren't so welcoming and so I started
wondering why is it that I'm part of a
faith where I feel so strange and so
almost alienated so what I did was I
started exploring other religions I can
maybe Hinduism Buddhism Christianity
Judaism and I started looking into all
these things but somehow I lost count
I'll have protected me and I was able to
come to the conclusion that you do not
judge a religion based on the way how
the people are and it's easy to say that
but you hear Muslim saying this all the
time
don't judge religion based on the people
judge it by its core values as for
myself it was a difficult experience
however upon realizing that I was so
ignorant about Islam that propelled me
to think well before I write off this
religion I need to first commit myself
and understand it deeply so I decided to
continue my journey of memorizing the
Quran that hamdullah and I finished him
when I was about 15 and then I got
accepted into the University of Medina
when I was 17 years old and I was
probably one of the youngest to ever go
to Medina and I spent one year in Arabic
over there and I spent five the next
four years doing a focus on a PITA and
our theology and missiology so how did
you get to this point where you got
through the doubtful and that's because
some people now they're at a crossroads
they don't experience this love let's
say it's this harshness which it's not
that islam teaches the opposite
antithesis to this that it's about love
and mercy but you know we have
deficiency as human beings obviously so
now you had an opportunity to go maybe
how old were you at that time 17 17 oh
that's like the peak now you know what I
mean that you know you can either go and
explore other avenues like the
nightclubs right chasing women all these
things that you know we shouldn't be
doing we should be submitting to God and
living a wholesome life but you you
stayed with it what what kept you like
pursuing you know going into looking at
other religions where this is kind of
odd
for a seventeen-year-old and then you
actually came back and realized that
indeed this is the true from the crater
and you explored other religions too so
the actual timing when I started
doubting was like around when I was
fifteen and a half to sixteen I started
exploring other religions and I found
that a lot of those other religions just
simply did not make much sense to me I
started reading deeply about the way of
how they derived their sources of
knowledge there was no sense of like a
an agreed-upon Athleta or theology and
so as a result I had to just sort of
stay with what I knew at that time so my
conclusion was before I jumped ship on
to something else I need to there has to
be two things number one is I need to
know exactly what I'm jumping to that
I'm comfortable with it and number two
is that I'm fully satisfied that the
thing that I'm leaving is something that
I'm not interested anymore and so
because these two things were not there
I decided that I will stay with whatever
I have at the moment and alhamdulillah
it was the right decision by the grace
of a West hometown well what was it now
I I had the similar experience
I wanted to know that Islam provided all
the truth to provide that to show it was
it was it was indeed the true based on
proof right so I did the same thing and
maybe similar opened up a world religion
book and just at the face of them like
you say it doesn't make sense but the
more you explore Islam it just goes with
the brain and the faculties that God
gave us to recognize that it is indeed
the truth simple to understand yeah yeah
so tell before we go to break tell us uh
so you went to to Medina you finished
you in in theology yes and what happened
from there well I finished my degree
there and I was really interested in
pursuing higher studies and I felt that
maybe I could use this as an opportunity
to get like a diploma in Dawa but then I
thought it's more important that I get
down experience by going back to the
United States back to United State we're
gonna take a break and we're gonna
continue on with your one of a story
here on a Deen show don't go nowhere I
started asking deeper questions
the question I want people to really ask
themselves is when you come back from a
night on the town
you've been drinking you've been boozing
you've been dancing then you hanging out
with girls guys or whatever number one
did you improve yourself is human being
number two did you contribute anything
to the betterment of humanity the
amazing thing is is that the most
advanced studies in psychology about
human happiness show that these are the
two key factors in making people
profoundly happy I take five minutes out
of my day and prayed to the Creator and
none of the creations and I feel a deep
internal peace and I still have my
normal life back here on the Dean show
with Sheikh Chou 17 years old you were
doubt in Islam right and then you
explored what were some of the rigid
religions that you explored Buddhism
Buddhism Hinduism what about
Christianity indeed of course Jesus if
you don't believe that he's your Lord
and Savior you going to the Hellfire
what happened there that I mean that's
that's a bold statement it is so how did
you conclude that this wasn't the way
that Jesus wasn't God he didn't die for
your sins
talk to us honestly it's the very very
common idea that I simply could not wrap
my head around Trinity or the idea of
trinitarianism it just did not make any
sense
I thought to myself well if I have to
spend so much time and effort to try to
wrap my head around it then I think I'm
gonna move on to Judaism and see what's
in there so don't just simple you didn't
have to go to I mean what about okay you
couldn't wrap yourself about around
Trinity God the Father Son Holy Ghost
where Islam's there's one God right and
don't add to it don't delete from it but
what about Jesus paying your bill the JC
gold card I call it you know and it's
easy way just believe that this mighty
messenger that people say he's God that
we
love and we're not trying to offend
nobody we're just trying to politely
help people to understand what about
that the crucifixion that someone died
for your sins now you can just hey do
what you want or not do what you want
but you got somebody that you can lay
your sins out when I first did what I
first started reading about Christianity
one of the most important aspects that I
or two important aspects that I felt
about it was this over emphasis on
putting faith before reason that's the
first thing that was like the first red
flag now this is not in any way trying
to say that anyone who studies
Christianity they put emotions before
faith that's no way I'm trying to
insinuate that but that's the feeling
that I got and the second thing was this
over emphasis on God's love and I I felt
at the beginning that's very very nice
God bring you a Savior so that you don't
have to go to go to hell for your sins
but then as I kept thinking about it I
couldn't help but feeling really sorry
for Jesus mhm and I just thought why is
it that he should pay for our sins it
just doesn't make any sense
so I started thinking well since I was a
kid I always had to be responsible for
what I've done
so why is that someone that I've never
met how can I be so sure that he's gonna
be willing to take on the heinous crimes
that I commit commit against almost kind
of hotarla so it was it was this sort of
this question that's going on in my head
and I really couldn't wrap my head
around it okay so you moved on then I
moved on now just for the night yet
Muslims our brothers who we love in
humanity he said it a few times a law
and uses want Allah someone you know who
never heard this name will explain this
well among Muslims we use the word Allah
which in Arabic it just literally means
the God some people they have this idea
that Allah is a God that's only for
Muslims it's not a universal Lord and
Allah is just coming it's coming from
the Arabic root word of El Allah means
the God it's similar like for example in
Judah in Biblical Hebrew when you find
words such as Elohim or Adonai or Allah
all of these words are just pretty much
saying that's just the same it's one God
so Allah is not a special God that's
exclusive for Muslims Allah
it means the God the one who created the
universe the one who we devote our
worship to the God for the whole world
that's the God that Jesus when he fell
on his face in Gospel of Matthew 26:39
he prayed to Allah to the one God yes
that's the guy we're talking about
absolutely not the moon or the Sun or
anything creation but the crate or the
one got absolutely beautiful now you can
rest assured that we're not worshiping
anything in creation but the one create
torque now you moved on to Judaism what
happened from here
I looked into Judaism and because I
didn't have much background in
understanding Islamic jurisprudence
I was extremely overwhelmed by the sheer
amount of fifth opinions that they had
you find it in the Talmud in the Midrash
thick thick opinions what do you mean
jurisprudent jurisprudence he was in
don't like do's and dont's laws Jewish
laws halakhah clause which is the Jewish
word for like filth and halal and Haram
things yes or no things I felt very very
overwhelmed by these things and the
concept of God is very very simple one
God but I felt that it wasn't answering
some of my deeper questions
it wasn't answering some of my deeper
questions such as well how does Judaism
respond to Jesus's message
how does Judaism respond to Muhammad's
message and because there was this void
and felt like the story just got cut off
so it feels like the story needs to be
explained further to me and so I moved
on to another religion to seek more
guidance on another faith that I could
take Judaism itself like we have the
unique thing about Islam obviously it's
not named after a person in place a
geographical location it just means what
does it mean submission submission to
who to Allah to the Creator that's it
but Judaism isn't it's named after a
tribe or and then Christianity after
Christ Buddhism after Buddha can you
elaborate on this for a second well for
a very very long time Muslims have have
tried to emphasize on
the purity as well as the message of
what Islam is bring and that is Islam or
LSD slams submitting to allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala and by pointing to that fact
you have to talk about the naming of
other religions such as Buddhism which
is named after Siddhartha Gautama or you
have Christianity which is for the sake
of you know to make it simple after
Christ and Christ being the word from
the Greek word of Messiah or like to
anoint so as a result I would say that
Islam is a very very unique religion in
which it's not named after anything but
for the concept and the core value that
a teaching that is to submit to Allah
subhanAllah
can we safely say emphatically that the
first man the father of a saw Adam he
was upon Islam yes but I would clarify
that he was on Islam with a lowercase I
Aslam that came with an uppercase I came
when Muhammad SAW said Allah brought the
message of Islam to the arabs in mecca
and that was the completion of Islam as
a religion as for the dawn of mankind
all the way until Muhammad peace be upon
him it was with a lowercase I the
continuous theme of submitting to Allah
the one creator can we just make an
analogy quickly from like a car that's
on the assembly line and is getting
completed but now with the last and
final messenger no more messengers that
come accepting Jesus Abraham Moses and
no and all of them that this was in its
in it was in its works is it can we can
you know stand like that I think in a
sense yes but I would probably maybe
suggest that it's basically like a
complete car because you say that it's
on an assembly line that means the car
is still being mine I see I see I see I
see but it's maybe you can think of it
as like a car that's going through
different improvements over time and so
sometimes you're gonna get like leather
seats sometimes you're gonna get like
power windows all these things and you
know the manufacturing the car company
they just add things from
time and that's very very similar to
what a la semana hotel it does and he
puts different rules for different
groups of people and so you'll find that
there are similarities and differences
from the monotheistic religion but the
core message the worship of only the
Creator not his creation one God pure
monotheism not worshiping Muhammad or
Jesus or anything in creation and then
establishing prayer paying the charities
as Akkad the the fasting the pilgrimage
what was this something that we could
say safely this core was with all the
messengers honestly I would probably say
that in in essence yes but as to the
details of how they work from religion -
religion is different so yes within
Judaism you find or in Christianity you
find the concept of of giving penance
giving sadaqa but in Islam it's a
different concept but the theme is there
the idea of fasting you find it not in
the same rules but it's the it's the
idea behind it that you give up food and
drink for a greater cause was Jesus a
Muslim yes
someone says look before we got we got
like 45 second before we go to break
back this up I would say that yes indeed
I believe that Jesus was a Muslim you
look through the Bible for example you
will find so many different instances
where Jesus is calling people to the
submission of allah subhanahu wata'ala
you never find anywhere in the Bible
where Jesus is calling to calling the
people to worship him as the Lord never
okay let's take a break and we'll
continue on we'll be right back here
with Sheikh cow on the Dean show
everybody in deep down they believe that
there is a God yes and as much as they
you
unhappiness Krupa found peace trooper
tranquility is by following the guidance
that God has given
you
there's some truth in life
I am Not Afraid to stand alone
if allies by my side I am Not Afraid to
stand alone I am Not Afraid to stand
alone
if allies by my side I am Not Afraid to
stand alone I am Not Afraid to stand
alone
if allies by my side I am Not Afraid
back on the Dean show which Sheikh Chao
he's taking us through his journey you
doubted now is there any doubt left no
no doubt no doubt
because Islam does it does it provide
all the evidence that a person needs
emphatically to come to a firm
conviction that this is indeed not
man-made because we shouldn't have to
follow it organized religion organized
by men or man but that it is indeed
organized by the one who created us yes
I yes I think that what you said is a
hundred percent true it is something a
process where I went through I had some
doubts and it's a little bit different
from like reverts because a lot of
reverts they come to hear about the
message of Islam and then they start
understanding it and they accept it for
me it was a reverse process questioning
my own existence questioning my identity
trying to validate what I actually
believed now you actually also just
briefly tell us you went to pursue your
master's also talk about this so after I
came back from Medina University I
started doing Dawa and I felt that I was
successful up to a certain level that I
was able to engage Muslims on a very
simple level of saying whether this is
right whether that is wrong but there
were two things that I felt that I
needed to improve on myself and that is
number one I needed to pursue more
understanding of religion as a whole
with particular emphasis on Christianity
so that I can dialogue with Muslims
better as well as with Christians
so in between 2009 and 2011 I was
accepted for the master's program master
of theological studies at Vanderbilt
University out in Nashville and it was a
great opportunity for me to be exposed
to Christianity and other especially the
Western Way of understanding religion
and how has it been so far your journey
with that you completed it yes I
completed it last year alhamdullah and I
would say that and I know it's probably
shocking to a lot of people I better
understood Islam after going to
Vanderbilt
and the reason I would probably say that
is after learning about Christianity and
the other religions I came to appreciate
Islam more not because that I studied
another religion in order to validate my
own religion it was there were certain
interesting ways of how other religions
view their own text some things that
maybe I didn't get exposed to while I
was in Medina of critically thinking of
being able to deal with certain topics
in a rational way from so many different
perspectives and be able to engage with
all types of people from all walks of
life this is an experience that a lot of
students that study overseas like in the
Middle East they don't get so going to
Vanderbilt really enhanced my way of
thinking about Islam from a broader
picture and also trying to bridge that
gap between the constant struggles that
Muslims are in when it comes to well
Christianity is wrong or Judaism or
Buddhism is wrong what I aim to do is we
don't need to validate our religion by
proving another religion is wrong we
need to first study our religion first
in order to understand it through to a
true we didn't talk about Hinduism and
some of the other religions you looked
into briefly so people don't go have to
go all around the world we can kind of
give them a shortcut what did you find
about these religions we took we touched
upon Christianity Judaism and your
exploration in brief we got like a
couple more minutes left I think I also
explored Buddhism because my mother she
converted from Buddhism into Islam Allah
lion hunt and I thought well maybe I
should look into Buddhism but I felt
that this was something that I should at
least make sure that something I want to
know so I went in looked into it and I
finally realized that within Buddhism
there is actually no theology and for
some people they might think that it's
not true but I really couldn't get my
finger on a particular theology on the
oneness of Allah or God or whatever it
is
now as for Hinduism it was another
problem for me at least because I
couldn't wrap my head around the idea of
God
being in so many different forms and
that's just really one God but they're
just emanations and reincarnation the
one god old like more like pantheism
right absolutely yeah
I just couldn't understand it and I just
didn't feel too comfortable with trying
to wrap my head around all of this
theology that it's really one God but
these are all just different portraits
of the same God I couldn't understand
that yeah and now we're narrowing it
down because some people say all the
thousands of religions but men when you
come down to it it's really what is it
the two religions that are inviting
people are Christianity Islam absolutely
now the other ones are you're either
like pantheism pantheistic religions
so really it's we're making it simple
for the people you know at the face of
it you'll see just do the work just and
what I tell people just emphasize can
you go into this is just realize that
we're not self-sufficient that this
whole universe didn't come by chance and
just seek the guidance is ask the one
who created this and he'll facilitate a
way is this true I can tell from
experience that when I was in that
moment of doubt I realized my biggest
weakness was that I've tried to rely on
myself to find the truth and a lot of
times when you rely on yourself to find
the truth only Allah knows where you're
going to end up I'm gonna and all of us
sitting right here
at this moment we can only pray to Allah
so Allah that we will continue to be
steadfast on the religion of truth but
for me I am very very grateful to all
around to Allah that I wasn't drawn into
another religion or else I wouldn't be
sitting here right now yeah so can that
person who's confused looked so many
religions this one's saying they're the
true this one say they're the true
what's the first step did that person
that's confused
he liked he's been tuning into the DJ
and it makes sense that there's only one
creator you worship him alone don't
worship his creatures the crater's
creatures creation that he created but
now he still got some doubt what should
he do I think the the most important
aspect is to understand
the bedrock of each religion don't look
at some of the nice things within a
religion and judge that religion and
accept it based on those small issues
you need to understand the basic
fundamental principles so if you wanted
to understand whether Christianity is
the truth or not you need to go in and
ask is there an agreed-upon Athleta
among Christians a theology absolutely
not you go into so many different
denominations everyone has a different
understanding of who God is or who Jesus
is and how his role is when it comes to
our salvation but when it comes to Islam
a lot of times people have questions
like what about the issue of my job or
the beard or this and that and I would
say to them that's like back to the
example you gave about a car that's like
someone wondering is this Italian
leather or is this Spanish leather and
before you ask is this what kind of
leather this is you need to understand
the engine of this car if this engine is
sound
who cares if there are tinted windows
who cares but the thing is once you
understand that that engine is the right
engine that will move you on the road -
Jenna that's religion that you have to
take you have to ask yourself is this
something that I have found to be the
truth and if it is then take it mm-hmm
this has been a great experience hearing
your story it's always great sitting
with people such as yourself and we're
out of time so any closing comments and
suggestions also for those who have the
nametag Muslim but they were in a
similar or are in a similar situation
they go to the University and
everything's calling them the desire
start heating up is tough out there and
now they start doubting what advice do
you give form shape I would say very
very briefly two things number one is
learn from my mistake of almost writing
off a religion based on the way how
people treated me know the foundation of
that religion and go and study it
understand it before you come to a
conclusion that this religion or
whatever religion it is
either right or wrong that's the first
thing number two is for the past 10
years I realized that a lot of
individuals or young people in America
there's this revival and interest in
studying about Islam but I would say to
them that's just the first step you can
study all you want but if that's not put
into practice it doesn't matter how much
hadith you have you have to put
everything into practice and you have to
acquaint yourself with other Sciences
not just simply understanding hadith and
[ __ ] you know a tradition of the process
set up or jurisprudence but you need to
know other things so you can help the
community apply yourself and maybe get a
degree in psychology or medicine so
you're not just an imam but you're a
neat young man with skills in other
fields to help the Muslim community
thank you very much by the Creator God
Almighty rewards you Monica love people
thank you very much and thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Deen
show another human beings journey and
they went they doubted but they never
our brother chao sheikh chao never gave
up and he asked the crater and he has
certainty in the crater and he got to
experience the other ways and then he
realized that the way of submitting only
with the one who created you created him
this whole universe and everything in it
that's the way to go that's Islam it's
logical it's rational and if you like
what we had to say here today continue
to tune in and ask if you don't ask how
shall you receive so ask the one within
your self to guide you not Muhammad not
Jesus not Abraham nothing in creation
asked the one Creator who created
creation to guide you and he will
facilitate a way that is for sure
call us at